i am joined by my incredible date rossi
ross matthews
i mean you really are all a girl could
ever dream for oh oh
no i'm not
got that in that department and by the
way that's why this is gonna last that's
why it works right
i'm also joined by
anyone else's dream date as well our
co-host for the hour michelle turner and
kevin
frazier a dream date every once in a
while
um all right well it's time for us to
dive into this year's nominations now
let's check out the first category here
are the nominations for limited series
okay yeah the nominations for limited
series is i may destroy you
mayor of east town the queen's gambit
so good
the underground railroad which is one of
my favorite this year and juan division
so
innovative innovative innovative wow huh
what do you think is going to win well
this one this one this could be tough
because you heard the applause for
queen's gambit right hands
but i think the industry loved mayor of
east town so much and loved what kate
winslet did so much i think that that
could supplant queen's gambit yeah i
completely agree wins i'm here to save
y'all okay the angst queen's gambit wins
all right
we'll have to wait to find out and you
know we like to turn to our audience to
take hold let's see who they predicted
innovative tv marvel came to television
and it was
yeah it was different
it was exciting we got the origin story
of wanda and vision
so great innovative yeah absolutely all
right well let's talk comedy here are
the nominations for comedy series of the
year
kevin what are your thoughts well the
broadcast network loan um nominee
blackish yes cobra kai which was fun and
innovative and everyone's child watch
every teenager and i got sucked into it
hacks snuck up on me like nobody's so
good being smart gene smart gene smart
the flight attendant which oh my god
rosie perez we bow down
the kaminsky method ted lasso um and
penn 15 of course
you know there's a lot of talk that you
know this was originally ted lasso's to
win and all the hype was around ted last
when i still feel that they have enough
steam i still think that a lot of people
think that hacks could sneak in i do
want to say that
years later we're going to look back and
we're going to say wow
blackish should have got a little more
love absolutely since 2015 25
nominations they've won once for hair it
is an innovative show that has changed
the face of broadcast tv the
conversations we're having all the
conversations i think you're right it is
time to honor blackish and this is this
is its last season so i would love to
see the show go out with a win they
deserve it this is ted she here it is
tennessee you're right all right well
let's hear what our followers predicted
ted lasso and emily impact lasso
barely
edging emily and power wow
wow
interesting that's interesting all right
now it's time to look um at lead actress
in a comedy series michelle all right so
tracy ellis ross is nominated for
blackish we just talked about them as
well alice and danny for mom we love her
gene smart that's all we've been talking
about smart dean smart dean smart for
hacks 80 bryant for shrill
and then kaylee cuoco for the flight
attendant
and i have to tell you guys so
word on the street is that this could be
coming down to a two-woman race
between gene smart for hacks and kaylee
cuoco for the flight attendant
why is the flight attendant a comedy
have you seen it i've seen it i loved it
it's hilariously ridiculously absurdly
yummy and crazy
i laughed out loud yes i thought it was
one of the best series of the year but i
didn't think it was a cop i looked and i
was like it's a mystery maybe you could
call it a dramedy but i think it was
comedic i think it was extremely comedic
well in the industry a lot of the times
um they call it a dark comedy yes which
is one of the hardest genres to be
successful please take it for me as a
producer they don't work most of the
time a dark comedy is something people
gr like grapple with i don't know why
but they do that's real yeah i'll tell
you what i don't grapple with jean smart
and hacks right they think it's hers i
think it has to be hers you know she
created this character that is so
layered hilarious and heartbreaking at
the same time it is a masterclass
performance in hacks she is having a
moment now let's see who our followers
predict we'll win
who would he who do we have
smart 25 25
they're on the money you do have a
really smart audience yes you've got a
super smart audience i'm telling you
they have a crystal ball it is freaky
i can't wait to see if their predictions
come true we have to take a quick break
but when we come back we are diving into
the most anticipated categories of the
2021 emmys that's right we're talking
all things drama
[Music]